let's get more on the news that helping
former prisoners find work or training
could save the government at least a
billion pounds a year the report by
unlocked graduates found that only four
in ten people released from custody each
year end up in employment that those in
work were significantly less likely to
reoffend well joining us in the studio
is between a Jordan barber senior
consultant for prisoner for prison
consultants must see that you know and
explain your length enters between
employment post incarceration and and
the kind of the drop in recidivism
because for some people it would seem
the case that you know you're in prison
you've committed a crime you serve your
time you come out of prison and you
return to your normal life that's that
that's not the way from us prisoners
it's not the way for most prisoners at
all regrettably there there is a
situation where every offender ends up
with two prison sentences the one they
serve in prison and then the one they
serve which starts on the day of their
release and they matter what our views
are on an ex offenders crime we as a
society needs to start working towards
reducing the huge bill that recidivism
costs 15 billion pounds a year is what
it's costing the UK taxpayer and that
doesn't include the cost to social
services or NHS if you look at what what
gives a person self-esteem and pride
everybody needs work everybody's family
everybody needs support and we need to
stop disenfranchising someone who has
paid for their crime because of their
crime so where does the problem lie then
does the problem lie within prison in
that there aren't enough training
programs in place that isn't reeducation
in place for prisoners who want to do
something different when they emerge or
is it that when we leave prison people
are start from simply turning up their
noses at their job applications it's
absolutely a combination of the two so
you know there's been lots recently on
the state of our prisons the you know
we've got a prisoner state of 86,000 in
an estate that can only cope with 72,000
if you're simply warehousing your stock
and your
rehabilitating them and you're not
reading them and you're not giving them
the skills with which to survive and
they haven't got a home to get you when
they get out of prison then all these
problems arise at the end of it you've
also got the situation where banks
Lloyd's Barclays they were arbitrarily
close someone's bank accounts purely
because they've had a conviction it
might not even be a conviction related
to money or fraud that prevents that
person from being able to function as a
normal person and society you have to as
you rightly pointed out there are lots
of things that where you have to declare
your conviction as an early stage in any
kind of recruitment process so you're
not even getting to put your face in
front of some somebody who might say
actually I'm going to give this person a
shot but what you're talking about
though some people will see is this
you're giving people who have committed
crimes opportunities that those who have
not committed crimes do not react a shin
training courses and these all costs
money inside or outside of prison why
should someone who is committed in the
fence knowingly why should they be
receiving a benefit as a result of their
of their criminality again it comes back
to deciding what we wanted a society no
matter what our view is of somebody's
crime if you want to reduce the
recidivism bill to this country then you
have to do a branch and route review of
the whole system and that includes what
you were asking earlier about what goes
on in prison and what happens from the
day they leave prison they've committed
a crime absolutely they've paid for that
crime and then when they come out you
know in order that they don't reoffend
you need you need you need to give them
something to work to some people who are
in prison or completely illiterate so
it's unfair to suggest that they're
getting an advantage over someone that's
outside of prison in the realm of
employment are you suggesting that
employers shouldn't be privy to the
information that somebody they're
potentially thinking of employing has
had a conviction in the past is that
something you'd like to see done away
with I'm not suggesting that they
shouldn't I'm suggesting that it should
come at an appropriate stage or if it's
appropriate for that role so clearly
teaching
you know there are certain professions
where it has to be declared and I
understand that but if on an application
form you're having to tick a box that
says whether or not you have a
conviction and that already prevents you
getting any further than that is unfair
because someone that's convicted of a
crime doesn't mean they're going to
reoffend in the same way you could have
it you could have an application from
someone who may have convicted it may
have committed a crime but hasn't been
found out yet but the kind of that way
but there will be employersioux said
look if I have 10 candidates in front of
me and I need to whittle them down one
entirely fair way of doing it would be
to suggest those that have a criminal
record should go to the back of the
queue and people who haven't I
completely disagree and people who
haven't committed crimes and people who
haven't spent time in prison might be
slightly more favorable to that no I'm
sorry i completely disagree with that
that perspective and companies like
timpson companies like Greg's they would
agree with my view on that it is I'm not
suggesting that there should be
favourited I'm suggesting an equal
playing field i'm not i'm not suggesting
that just because someone come out of
prison that they should be given a
forward leap but if you don't give
someone a future they will potentially
return to their path see that Jordan
Bubba thank you very much for joining
see my pleasure